nice there the bed where 17 year old
psychology student yamilet arokipa used
to sleep no longer has blankets or
sheets
the indigenous custom is to remove them
forever eight days after a person dies
that's her when she was small
there she is playing in her school band
the family of four has been in mourning
since January 9th when police fired live
rounds of protesters in the city of July
we had gone to the market to buy food we
were not in the protest we're two blocks
away and suddenly she was shot
they've killed my daughter and other
Innocents we want justice justice is
what we ask for
eign
the government suggests stones and
sticks thrown by protesters were
responsible for the 18 people killed
that day in kuliaka
but the autopsy report states that
jamilet was killed by a nine millimeter
bullet confirming with the family
already believed
julyaka has turned into one of the
epicenters of anti-government protests
in the puno region of Southern Peru
since former president Pedro Castillo
was impeached and imprisoned seven weeks
ago when he tried to shut down Congress
these people that you see here have been
walking all night to reach the the city
of julyaka they're from all over the
puno region and as you can see they are
still very very much determined to keep
on protesting to keep on blocking roads
and to keep on demanding that the
president stepped down
[Music]
the March ends in the Central Square
where we find what looks like a typical
Carnival but in fact it's a fundraising
event
today we are using our music to collect
funds for our brothers who have suffered
the repression of the state where many
are still suffering from severe injuries
others tell us they're collecting money
to send more groups to the capital Lima
to join the indigenous protesters who
are already there
[Music]
demanding immediate elections and the
ouster of the president
army helicopters fly overhead but so far
nearby troops have not moved in to
unblock highways
losing three times Congress has now
agreed to reconsider president Dina
boluarte's demand to bring forward
general elections for October
an offer that at least here seems to
have fallen on deaf ears
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera juliaka